we were on the ground yesterday in Miami
Florida our correspondent Luke Beasley
whose YouTube channel you can find at
davidpackman.com Luke was there and he
spoke to a Litany of trump supporters we
were trying to figure out at this point
this isn't even the first indictment
this is the second indictment serious
crimes 37 felonies the indictment is
extraordinarily detailed and tight as
Chris Christie and others have referred
to it who is still defending this guy
and we got the answer and it is really
really scary Luke doing an incredible
job the conspiracy theories that come
out of the mouths of the people still
defending the sky tell us a lot about
the cultish nature the cult members are
the ones that are left here are two
young ladies with a wild conspiracy
theory they believe Trump is still
president they are slurring badly and
they seem confused by even what they are
telling Luke listen to this what are
your thoughts about the arraignment
Candace
The Witch Hunt but we do believe that
President Trump is actually protected
under the continuity of government I
believe he's our authentic president and
that we are watching a movie oh really
so he's the current president of the
United States I believe
that what is Biden doing then well Biden
is um
we're under a continuity of government
it's a military
um action okay so this is where this
happens with every one of these folks
that Luke interviews as soon as you ask
any follow-up they start to look
confused about what's coming out of
their own mouths that's the commonality
the Common Thread between all of these
and so they're showing the people in
slow motion the corruption and all the
different
uh elements uh all the different
agencies and the Dual system so they're
saying okay if you want to steal the
election which they did this is what
you're going to get so then how is Biden
doing in his role is he the president
right now no Biden is an actor but I
think Biden is has been gone a long time
that's how I feel gone dead gone dead
he's gone dead the one walking around uh
an actor
do we know who the actor is and why
would they pick an actor who looks frail
and sometimes Falls right like why would
you do that there's different ones that
play him everybody has actors but I know
it sounds so far-fetched but yeah they
say that they're going to reveal it soon
okay
trick of it who's they by the way that
are going to reveal it this is is
protecting we the people I do believe
he's actually the king it sounds pretty
crazy instead of make America great
again it's going to be make the Earth
great again right and so for those of
you who thought that George Washington
uh decided that the U.S would not have
Kings I guess you were wrong I guess
Trump is actually King right now if
you're wondering why they aren't
abandoning Trump based on what is going
on this is why these are the people that
are still defending this guy here's
another guy Luke spoke to this guy has
coveted conspiracies a woman walks over
and warns the guy that Luke is on the
left and then the guy demands fauci be
killed this is very serious stuff that
these are sick sick people oh Kobe
there's a government-made virus yeah as
a government made by
the woman says this guy's a total
liberal he's probably going to change
what you say and of course as you can
see we are playing it uninterrupted no
edits no Cuts it's like this stuff these
people don't get this stuff is so crazy
why on Earth would we edit it there's no
way to edit it to make it crazier yeah
of course we can talk to liberals yes
it's a government-made virus they said
okay came from a lab if it came from a
lab it is a it's a weapon of Bio Warfare
and then they followed up this is a
depopulation operation that they're
doing my audience is less familiar so we
gotta walk through step by step by the
way a depopulation operation with a
virus that kills 0.6 of the people it
infects that's what this guy's alleging
say the creating of the virus and for
what purpose it's a deep stage it the
globalist uh Bill Gates a world economic
Forum claw Schwab the gang from Davos
this has been in the works for a long
time was the covet an effort to get
Trump out of office I think I think in
part in combination they've been
planning uh if you listen to uh Dr
bouchi fauci before he even entered
office said that he's gonna have to do
falchi what what is wrong with these
people falchi deal with the pandemic
they've been planning this for a long
time he said I'm going to have to deal
with the quote unquote pandemic he
didn't say a pandemic but he said
there's going to be a pandemic on his
watch and there are people have been
predicted he's been working for decades
oh yeah he he you know what Anthony
Bolton needs to be locked up you should
be hanging from a tree
hanging from a tree
the we wonder why the indictment doesn't
change their minds about Trump and he
says falchi should be hanging from a
tree same guy also says the FBI did
January 6th these are the people still
supporting Trump I was is that January 6
January that's that's not a shocker six
was visited by the FBI
[Music]
oh yeah so then why would the FBI in uh
consultation with or coordination with
the Democrats want to stop the
certification of Biden's win oh they
didn't stop the certification Biden's
when they were four Biden's when the FBI
and the CIA are corrupt they were behind
the hole right the FBI and CIA
in order to help Biden organized a riot
to try to hurt Biden why don't you guys
understand this it's so obviously
okay so focusing on January 6th why
would the FBI want to create January 6
and frame Trump supporters oh because
they want us to make us look like we're
white supremacists they want us to lock
us up there is half of the January six
people that are in the DC Gulag Gulag
okay uh this is sickness this is
sickness we have to just say this is not
people saying hey you know I want to
engage in the political system so I'm
going to evaluate the political
positions of the candidates and make a
decision this that's not what's going on
okay Luke actually uh randomly came
across a sort of well-known
uh he they he go he's called a Maga
rapper his name is Forgiato blow I don't
know if that's a given name or a
nickname Forgiato blow uh says he has a
whole new song about what's happening at
Target which he doesn't seem to actually
understand Luke tries to explain it to
him I'm here
I'm here Target yeah
yeah it's pretty cool stuff heck yeah
and what motivated you to write that
song
and pretty much
so as I was just telling the man before
it's not like an anti-gay song you know
it's an anti-pudding
children
Pride clothes with bathing suits where
you can up tuck your genitals in but
they didn't do that right target did do
that no that's been like the bunk to 30.
and on the screen right now there are
all sorts of Articles debunking the idea
of Tuck friend Leaf clothing for kids
like not that this guy cares but it's
been widely debunked Luke is completely
correct it's not bad debunked I've been
in Target I've been hold the hell to us
for adults no there's a children's site
you want to see right now on my stuff I
promise that that's only in adult sizes
not adult sizes you want to see the
children's stuff I have it yeah remember
the claim was tuck up tucking uh uh
things for children this children
clothes okay celebrating pride month
these are children clothes this is just
like a shirt by the way yeah you told me
tuck it
no all the pride clothes you think any
Pride clothes are bad telling a child
hey whoever you are straight maybe
wearing a shirt my man a rainbow kid in
the third grade needs to be wearing a
shirt that says trans life matter okay
so first the claim was that they have
tuck clothes for kids to tuck genitalia
now it's just something that says trans
lives matter which of course was not the
original claim that that Forgiato blow
made then we go to a woman who seems
truly sick she gets extremely close to
Luke super super close and she seems to
be warning him about something it's hard
for me to tell you what she's warning
Luke about but it is a warning
don't worry
American that's what they want to finish
the white American is the last one in
the list I guess she's telling Luke that
because he's white the left the left is
gonna do something bad to him
is coming
what makes you believe that when you're
gonna do you have a song that goes to
the university she has a song that will
explain it
in the University he's the last in the
least because he's he looks like you and
the last name and I'm 54 years old a
motivation that you have I have already
like an x-ray video's older than you
doesn't mean he's wiser than you no no
he's older than me and thick oh okay she
this woman is wiser than Luke because
she's older but Biden even though he's
older than this woman is not wiser
because he's sick
it's a Democratic Republic
all right so so this is uh you know
these are the folks that are supporting
him now and we're like oh maybe they'll
change their mind wow last one okay
here's a woman who says that Obama is
actually running the country right now
and he's running it in a racist way I
don't know
Obama's racist biggest racist are you
are you see black you think
you think are you kidding me so Obama's
it's funny how some of these people say
it's really Trump running the country
others say it's really Obama it would be
great to get them together to argue
about who's actually running the country
died recently was uh head of the KKK for
a while and buy and actually applauded
him
right so but the Obama part's
interesting to me so Obama is running
the country
in what capacity
what he said he wanted to do six years
ago he said I'd be happy running the
government from my basement and that's
what he's doing you don't think Biden is
do you
I happen to yeah you think that man is
making any decisions he doesn't even
know what day it is that's literally a
quote from Trump verbatim I have him so
medicated no I'm sorry my father
it's a joke and let me tell you
something else that's the last thing I
want to say if you own the mainstream
media you can do anything you want to
because you're keeping the truth from
the people who owns the mainstream media
Jews oh oh no
I'm a I'm a Jewish girl so I can say
that okay my people are destroying this
country they run the Democrat Party they
run Hollywood they run the education
system are you kidding me you mentioned
the Obama's race it's because of what
he's doing in power right now what is he
doing this racism for America for but
what's the racist part of it look what
he well he's black Luke isn't that
racist enough going to the gay community
you don't think what he's doing is
hurting them
but homosexuality is not a race right no
no no I'm talking I'm jumping I'm
jumping around you gotta fight we can
tell you're jumping around ma'am
the racism in this country started with
Obama
so listen Luke doing the best he can
it's sort of like if I hand you a rotten
banana
and some Blades of grass and tell you to
make beef wellington or a nice chanukkah
brisket
um you're gonna struggle because I'm not
giving you the right material
uh Luke doing the absolute best he can
with some really rotten material make
sure you're subscribed to Luke's Channel
davidpackman.com Luke make sure you're
subscribed to this channel we will
continue to be on the ground
to the extent people want us to do it we
will continue to be on the ground
throughout the 2024 primary and election
all I ask of you is make sure that
you're subscribed to our audio podcast
or hit that subscribe button on YouTube
let's take a break catch our breath
collectively see if we can recover from
that and then we will continue
here is the perfect Father's Day gift
get him a Wi-Fi connected digital
picture frame from Aura our sponsor Aura
has been named the number one best
digital picture frame by wire cutter the
strategist and wired this is not one of
these early 2000s picture frames there's
no USB or SD cards and you get free
unlimited storage and you can instantly
frame photos and videos from any device
anywhere in the world I have several of
these I got my dad one and so now I take
pictures of the baby load them into his
or a frame and they show up and
everybody loves it you know it's no more
of these having to bring a slideshow
When I visit I just put the pictures
right in the frame I'm really glad I got
him one of these and right now Aura has
a great deal for Father's Day go to
auraframes.com Pacman use the code
Pacman to get thirty dollars off plus
free shipping this deal ends June 18th
so don't wait terms and conditions apply
the link is down below